my buddy Charles Davis this is directly
up his alley as is anything to do at the
NFL Draft in football and just life in
general right here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you sir I'm doing great
it's good to hear your voice
I'm doing your family are well they do
one that they can hear our voices
hopefully everybody good with you so yes
so far so good we just did ourselves
porch well good so we've got a hell of a
lineup here Charles you're first up von
miller DJ and then the Commissioner of
the NFL two actors jeffrey wright of
Westworld and then at the very end
Tom Everett Scott is going to join us
because the wonders from that thing you
do are getting back together for a watch
party later today to help raise money
for music cares covered 19 relief fund
and I put that on my top on my Mount
Rushmore of Tom Hanks movies almighty
leader the o-neders correct and so we we
were wondering what your what your Tom
Hanks Mount Rushmore would be oh god
well I heard you talking about big and I
don't think there's any way you can get
past that I thought he was sensational
in that you know for me burst on the
scene a bachelor party but I saw that in
college and then it's not a college
movie like it's just absolutely perfect
not a movie right so when he was uncle
when he was uncle Ned on Family Ties was
somewhat inappropriate if I'm not
mistaken Charles it was one of the few
times that Tom Hanks was a heel any in
anything he would be he was beyond
inappropriate he hit Alex
for godsakes 10 and dad jumped in and
said get help or get the hell out of my
house oh my gosh ladies and gentlemen
charles davis go on family ties on us
here alright let's get into it Charles
we come on the air one week from today
and the conversation from the previous
night's draft what are we talking about
what is the lead story do you believe
predicting round one best you can well
look it's gonna be if indeed - it does
actually start a little bit of a fall
and what I mean by a little bit of a
fall does he not get plucked
Miami if they get advance or does a team
come up and jump them and take another
quarterback in order to ensure they got
their guy
Bucky Brooks put in his last mock draft
which I thought was very interesting the
tool could slide to 9:00 and
Jacksonville would halt the slot oh my
gosh they should light a candle right
now Charles right they should light a
candle in Duval County for that right
now and you and you guys remember enrich
you were you were omnipresent that night
when Dave Caldwell sent in Blake bortles
name at number three this is called no
he told nobody nobody knew told no one
yeah no one there's one of the group and
it it is day and age some of the best
subterfuge that you will ever have in an
NFL draft because didn't even whisper it
to anyone you know Steve's burger when
he quit Florida he told two people
before he quit
Dave Caldwell didn't even tell his bride
right well honey what do you think today
you'll find out with everyone else I'm
on my way out
see you amazing so that's that that to
me that's going to be the monster story
there we know where the receivers going
to get their run the tackles are going
to get their run I do think the Giants
at four is interesting because Dave Dave
gentlemen has never traded down all
right coach Galen was never got out of
the pick hmm but do you get the tackle
to protect Daniel Jones or what if Isiah
Simmons is sitting there and the DNA of
that franchise is very simply defense I
know
well he's gonna is definitely gonna be
sitting there Isiah Simmons and and that
is a fascinating choice what do you
think of that choice if you are get Ulm
inand you are a couple years in to your
tenure there and you've got that young
kid Daniel Jones you can you can
obviously supplement Daniel Jones by
getting him back on the field thanks to
Isiah Simmons or you can supplement
Daniel Jones by keeping him upright to
survey the field and/or hand it off to
say Quan ridges even before our lifetime
and through our lifetime the guys who
got the best tables in the New York New
Jersey Connecticut met
area that were giant were defenders they
always got the best tables they were
they were to celebrated stars it took
shores and everywhere else yeah but but
but coach gentlemen pick last year that
stunned a lot of people I know DJ had
predicted he would take him and he did
and he remember how the New York people
lost their mind oh yeah and by the end
of the year they knew they had a
quarterback I think you've got to take
care of that kid I just don't think that
you can continue on and keep trying to
jerry-rig an offensive line and keep
getting him hit and he will have his
pick I think if he stays there for of
any of those tackles now I would listen
to someone who wants to get in get up
there if I knew I wasn't going to get
out of range of getting a tackle that I
like and then you might be able to get a
tackle and someone else I'm not saying
it's necessarily Simmons at that point
but should continue to build your team
but he's never gotten out of a pick so
that would be a new thing for him well I
mean it's very rare that you would have
freaky athletic people at the
quarterback running back and left tackle
position or even right tackle position
because works can do both do you think
he goes worse do you think he would go
Will's or obviously Makai Becton who do
you want to talk freaky athletic he
nearly broke five seconds in the 48 at
19,000 pounds so in front of our eyes at
the combine Charles yeah and if the roof
if we had added open roof and the Sun
was shot he would have blotted that out
that's how big that man but here's the
thing I've known coach Coach gentlemen
since I was in high school all right and
I'm not saying I know him
absolutely but he told me since I was 16
years old
Charles is always gonna be a big man's
game Makai Becton is the biggest of the
tackles plus he has the athleticism plus
he's played left tackle it's not a
conversion like works in Jedrek wills
I'm not saying he wouldn't like worse
better support was amazing at the
combine as we all saw all right I mean
wills is an excellent player Thomas is
an excellent player but I would I would
I would go back to big and big as my
type
he sure is the hog Molly's right isn't
that the way that he refers to it the
hog Molly's love is how your first
alignment all right and so where do you
stand on the two oh Justin Herbert
evaluation that appears to be real right
now
maybe in places like Miami Los Angeles
for the Chargers or maybe somebody else
that might throw their hat into the ring
because they adore either one of these
two quarterbacks where do you Charles
Davis stand on that evaluation of those
two guys because that could be so
crucial as to how the top six picks play
out on Thursday night I like to uh
better than Herbert for this reason I
just think accuracy overall and every
time we talk to a quarterback coach rich
you've done it for years don't they
always tell you they downplay the arm
you know strength a little bit now you
have to have a minimum amount you can't
just be a total lollipop err but if you
know if you got a minimum amount and
accuracy is gonna be a tiebreaker they
take accuracy almost every single time
and I think that's - uh not that Herbert
is inaccurate it's not like when Josh
Allen came out we were all having oh god
can he hit targets can he do this can he
do that and some of that crops up on and
in that doing with Buffalo game late in
the season
remember Dawson knocks breaking in the
end zone and he airmailed it over him
but all in all I just think - is that
guy now obviously you go back to your
doctors etc etc but I think if there's
one year you might get a little bit of
leeway about not having all the info in
front of you I'd say this would be it
for an NFL GM hmm and Jordan Love is
sitting out there - I mean the whole
conversation we're having Boro and who's
clearly separated himself from the rest
I'll ask you the question Charles Davis
I have asked Daniel Jeremiah and I asked
Mel Kiper yesterday Trevor Lawrence is
in this mix do you take him over all of
them likely yes yeah I think I probably
do Burrell would be my wild card because
I still think even though the year he
had at LSU looks like a 148 is an
all-timer
I still think there's a lot more in him
I think there's a lot more to ascend - I
don't think that he's done
but but Trevor lords's he's gorgeous and
that hit look two years ago I got to
watch him
and Justin Herbert throw side-by-side
one summer and now that was fun
balls just jumping out of their hands
and receivers fighting each other to get
in line when those who were stepping up
to the line to throw the football
Charles Davis here on the Rich Eisen
show okay
ex tech equipment what are you doing
with them Charles what's going on oh
yeah I've known Bob Broderick and Ted
Monica the guys who started the company
in New Jersey for a while now and that
but they've worked hard rich to make
this now the number one pad in the NFL
and you think about guys who you know
you gotta protect yourself you know guys
with your body armor it's important to
players so for it to be the number one
pad not just shoulder pads but your
thigh your knee your hip everything else
your Jets guy but they got Sam Donald
back on the field they called X Tech
last year when you have the mono and it
at the enlarged spleen what can we do to
pad him up to give him extra protection
he was wearing that gear when he went
out went back out in the field
se Kwang Barclay wears it Oh BJ wears a
Khalil Mac wears it Matt Ryan where is
it any high school that you can think of
it's a big-time high school feels like
they're all wearing a modern-day De La
Salle st. John Bosco st. Thomas Aquinas
Michigan and Ohio State I saw a rich I
put them in the same sentence for you I
appreciate you put it in that order to
Charles you're a good man there you go
they're both wearing that pad I put my
son in them when he was playing in high
school had a shoulder injury here before
your play to senior year no issues
they're the best pad going next act as
combat extech pads on Instagram we're
gonna play football again rich we don't
know exactly we are so have your kids
ready to hit the ground running boy or
girl
put them in the right pass before they
go out the black horse of course the
choice of as you pointed out Pro Bowlers
and the choice of quarterbacks who get
high school kissing viruses and diseases
and all that sort of stuff yep oh my
gosh Oh Charles I just forgotten about
all that so give me give me players and
we're not
all good amount for the draft give me
guys give me guys that you you talked
about at the combine or you were gonna
talk about if combine we'd have a time
to talk about that or guys that have
risen up boards give me and give me give
me guys give me names cuz I don't have
him okay well look I think we talked
about Mooloolaba but Antoine Winfield to
safety I love I think he's sovereign
Tyrann Mathieu in terms of instincts
sighs - are very similar as well
Akeem Davis Gaither we didn't get a
chance to talk about a much DJ's
Appalachian State linebacker because the
whole thing to combine undersized but
can flat-out run and by the end of every
play he's wrapped around the ball
carrier can he get a little bit bigger
and will people be able to play him in
that inside spot like we've seen because
guys aren't that huge anymore maybe he
can still make that adjustment and play
another kisum a practice they Darrington
evans the running back I think he's an
absolute dart I love that kid he's one
of my favorite ones in this draft and I
can't wait to see what happens and
there's a running back from Memphis
Antonio Gibson has people are like is he
a receiver is he a running back I think
he's our running back all day long race
he had like like 14 touchdowns on 77
touches last year he finds his way into
the end zone we don't talk about it much
well-built kid maybe adjustment to pure
runner at the Senior Bowl I think that's
where he continues to go and he's one of
my flat-out favorites that we just
really haven't talked about much in this
traffic and in terms of quarterbacks
you're my Gruden whisperer because of
your history with John and nobody really
knows really I mean he loves he just
loves collecting him he loves bringing
him on and he loves collecting him and
he loves developing them and and and
many people interpret that to me he
never likes his his quarterbacks do you
think he and Mayock with the first
rounders that they have might go snag
one on Thursday night I might have
thought so rich until Mariota ended up
in town and now I think that they will
concentrate on continuing to make the
rest of the team better because Mariota
is a guy who has been a starter in the
league and as you said John likes to
collect them and bring them back to
health he's a guy that he thinks that he
can do that with and for me
the number one thing for Marcus to get
back to being the guy we saw come out in
the draft is to go back to trusting his
legs I thought he got away from that in
Tennessee I don't know if I got in his
head to stay in the pocket I don't know
if the broken leg broken ankle did it so
I don't know what it was that's just my
own opinion about him trust his legs a
little bit more go when that hole was
there and now he's breaking down
defenses again and so he'll be back
there behind Derek Carr for now you know
memory collected Nathan Peterman lashing
up I said don't do it
who are you getting and he's still on
the roster I don't think he's the factor
I think that Mariota is the factor cars
there this gives them a chance and
they've got to score point Mike told us
that you know the combine and he told us
that get throughout they move the ball
but it got a score point they will have
a if they just stick where they are at
12 they have a choice of one of the top
three receivers or do they sure do Judy
lamb or rugs can be sitting right there
or or it's entirely possible Mayock and
Gruden have a choice of all three right
yeah and then the question athlete you
know exactly because because where does
it start you know does Jacksonville
surprises a receiver I don't think so at
9 I think the Jets at 11 right
potentially and then we get them we get
to the Raiders at 12 and I think the
Raiders are what 12 and 20 so so there
you are and if they thought there's a
chance to drop back a little gain an
extra guy there will still be other
receivers available for them in the
first round I gotta tell you I know
Robbie Anderson the Jets let him go
right and you gotta you gotta hook darn
'old up with somebody really special
that has to happen he's that guy who you
believe in and the Jets fans believe in
and hope he is that transformational you
gotta hook them up with a huge playmaker
or you got to protect him and yep
they're you know Daniel deejay calls
this a Noah's Ark offseason for the Jets
that they need two of everything so if
you're Joe Douglas and you've got a
choice between one of those three studs
at receiver or somebody named wills or
Becton or
well I don't think we'll be there at
11:00 what do you do what do you do job
I'm going I'm going with the tackle rich
for this reason I think there's there's
deeper options that receiver in this
draft not saying there aren't other
options that tackle later but you're
starting to limit it we're out that
major run of those four you know we
could very well see a rip of them you
know they just start out and there's and
they just keep going like you know we
could go you know they could very easily
go seven to Carolina eight to the
Cardinals you know what I mean ten to
the ten to the Cleveland 11 to the Jets
so I would go get that guy because DJ
what does he told us 27 30 guys he's got
with top three grades we've been in the
draft and receivers right I might I
might have to fall back on that a little
bit yeah I want that special guy force
and Arnold but he can't throw it if he's
always getting hit he can't find that
special guy I need to have him and I
know they signed George fan but that's
not all you mentioned your DJ saying the
Noah's Ark okay who's the second one I'd
go get another one
so and then I guess before I let you go
charles davis into your game into your
Friday before the NFL Draft week begins
what do you think Bella checks thinking
at the quarterback spot with Brady and
Tampa and Brian Hoyer in there because I
guess you they can't quit him and then
there's Statham who is either
not-ready-for-prime-time or was the
choice outside of the top quarterbacks
in the first round last year of so many
other teams and he hopped on him and he
could be the Garoppolo of this equation
what do you think the Patriots are
looking at at the quarterback spot
either in this draft or when it's all
said and done what their room looks like
yeah I don't think that they force
anything on a quarterback that's never
been there
their style before Garoppolo was a
second-round guy you know it's not like
they just forced their way into it
thinks they I'm not saying they sit
there and let it fall but it would have
to be a real easy deal for them to go
make and to me if Jordan loves it's all
the way down gets all the way down there
that could be a possibility there's
still free agency out there I don't
think it's cam but I wouldn't pass off
on Jameis Winston you know I really
wouldn't because if there's one
organization things they can fix people
wouldn't you think it'd be New England
and the kid his issues have been much
more on the field and what he's done
with decision making than anything else
so that's where I would look at that's
how I would look at it with New England
but I don't think it's a huge
quarterback draft class I don't think
you know the third fourth fifth round
we're gonna find guys if you want them
you gotta go get them early and the
second wave is Jacob Eason Jake from
that crew I don't know and last thing I
would say is didn't coach Belichick
about a week and a half ago mentioned
you know we did ok with Matt Cassel ever
me no no you know they were eleven in
five and in a freaky year somehow this
the playoffs well Hertz is the guy out
there that that's the second round prize
to me that's the guy that you could go
get their rich what do you mean I
thought yeah what I mean is Teddy
Bridgewater was a trade back in to take
him at the end of the first Lamar
Jackson was a trade back in to take him
at the end of the first but waves of
contracts are structured someone might
do that with Jalen Hertz and come back
in and swoop and get it or you move back
and get him there so late first into the
second I'm with you on that part on
Jalen Hurd but he might be the wild card
that people might say them let's trade
back in late help ourselves out with the
contract and go get that young man
remember he's a gym rat he's a son of a
coach place for his dead high school
he's been doing X's and O's does they
put the pacifier in his mouth let's not
forget that about him too
Charles you're the man thanks again for
coming on talking draft extech and so
much more be Wells best your family
thanks Charles I will do that that'll be
Tom Everett Scott at the very end of
this show that's Charles Davis here on
the Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here